this April Steven Spielberg invites you
to journey back to a time before every
movie was leadless Lee converted to 3d
jurassic park now needlessly converted
to 3d revisit the adventure that
launched your childhood obsession with
dinosaurs and two really disappointing
sequels we experienced the
groundbreaking CGI that still holds up
after 20 years and all of this
technology that doesn't add re witness
the Goldblum enter a theme park full of
live dinosaurs made by impossible
science created by John Hammond a
terrible grandfather who will leave his
grandkids alone with complete strangers
and a t-rex when this incredibly
dangerous dinosaur Park faces inevitable
insurance problems
Hammet must finally hire a group of
people who actually know something about
dinosaurs dr. Alan Grant a brilliant
Dino bone scientist who loves to
traumatize children here dr. Ellie
Sattler an ancient plant scientist
person and dr. Ian Malcolm who actually
knows nothing about dinosaurs
Dino dropping together they will
experience a journey through a
state-of-the-art theme park that is
fully staffed and operational drop what
you're doing and leave now except for
when it rains stranding them in a deadly
zoo that spared no expense spent no
expense spared no expense spared no
expense
except for tougher fences more than one
security guard and emergency power
supply sturdier signs and paying the one
disgruntled employee who runs the entire
park
experience in 3d The Unforgettable film
that'll constantly remind you of the
film that you are currently watching
welcome to Jurassic Park the
electrifying excitement of watching a
kid in constant peril who cannot die the
unparalleled visual effects that
introduced audiences to the gif starring
land jaws your face
Papa Smurf brundlefly the Olsen twins
- I Nick Fury and the guy from Jurassic
Park Jurassic Park 3d oh man what an
awesome shot oh look at how the batter
falls I gotta watch this movie again
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
I feel the need the need for speed
previously on AMC's The Walking Dead
Bobbitt twisted pull it are no parts
transform and roll out I would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for those meddling kids